I love like that you're so capable and
like you can be like you're hanging with
Snoop Dog
what's I was with s um last week and he
was just great he came to New York and
and he was just a well-dressed uh Happy
how did you guys come together like cuz
on my show on my show he came in and
cooked uh brownies and he oh I bet made
some other stuff I've made some of those
brownies and he's a he's a lovely a
lovely guy he's very smart and good
family man he is a fabulous children
fabulous grandchildren who saw that
though like that chemistry and
connection and just did some brilliant
producers you guys are really a team and
it's like I just wouldn't have seen your
dog's head is so
heavy my hand is falling asleep it feels
like 100
lb maybe he sleeps too
much speaking of how do you feel about
naps Martha I've said on I've said that
I I have a very strong opinion about you
don't like naps I don't why I just it's
like I had a relationship with a guy who
just napped all the time made me sick to
my stomach oh and he just like napped
off when you were talking yeah just
always he was so tired all the time and
I a nap all the time and I was like
awful right and so it's it's really
about him I I actually take a cat nap in
the car would you date a man who didn't
work and naps all the time no didn't
work did I say that out loud yes didn't
work yeah no I would not but but um
that's not what I do I mean a nap a nap
when you're tired is good okay catch up
so you would date a
napper um I don't know I don't know if
he did other things you know if he were
most fabulous handsome man in the whole
world that I was madly in love with and
he wanted to take a nap every now and
then that's fine with me okay well I I I
wish to manifest that person are you
going out with somebody that's wants to
nap and you don't want him to nap my
dating life is a is such a hot mess that
I and I and this then this question I
asked myself why can't I meet someone
who like knocks me off my socks and I
think is hot I I I don't know what I I
got knocked out of my socks last week by
somebody and I mean just very attractive
I mean I still you don't you don't you
must meet a lot of guys where do you go
at night
home just so don't you go out to dinners
and parties and stuff your friends have
to be sitting sitting you next to ig
young man no I'm not living that life
Martha how do I do it you better start
you have a lot of friends and they
should be inviting you and taking they
didn't do that for me either by the way
I was going to say that I had to do it
myself and this man who knocked your
your so you know it it wasn't exactly
appropriate but um but it was it was
good for it was good for a night you
know
just nothing happened
nothing nothing happened we didn't go
home together or anything but it was
just like a little fation that's nice I
think at this point the only hedonistic
things I have in my life are like food
like food is a is a big pleasure for me
yeah and you cook or you go out do you
go out um sometimes you don't go out for
dinner sometimes not really I'm a kind
of a food delivery person oh no I know I
just I'm so boring do you know I have
never had food delivered to me
never well I want to do everything like
the way you do I want to be you I want
to be like you you have so much Moxy
energy hoods spy you're hot you're doing
it you've always been doing
[Music]
it